[Musique]
un nouveau géant canadien de l'or est en
train de voir le jour au canada avec
l'acquisition de kirkland lake gold à
agnico eagle le mariage de ces deux
entreprises va ici le nouveau groupe au
3ème rang des producteurs d'or dans le
monde
pierre lassonde fondateur de franco
nevada est avec nous ce soir bonsoir
monsieur la sonde bonsoir jal est un
plaisir de vous accueillir de nouveau à
l'émission pour parler de cette
méga-transaction comment vous la
qualifiez cette grosse transaction dans
le secteur de l'or
écoutez je trouve que c'est formidable
de la porte de chambre le cio de nico
parce que dans un seul mouvement
cette fusion va créer comme vous l'avez
dit un géant canadien de l'industrie
aurifère mais en même temps aussi au
géant canadien de l'industrie minière
point final faut bien penser que dans le
résultat
la compagnie va faire va produire plus
de 3.5 et 3.6 millions d'onces d'or par
année dont les deux tiers vont provenir
du canada ce qui fait que cette
compagnie doit être la plus grosse
compagnie aurifère canadienne et sa part
un facteur de 4 à 5 sur le deuxième plus
grand au canada alors voyez c'est une
énormité en terme fusion parce que c'est
vraiment une fusion où je dirais pas que
c'est un fake over c'est aussi un
manager c'est vraiment une fusion de ces
deux grandes compagnies d'eau pour que
nous pourquoi ça arrive monsieur la
sonde pourquoi c'est nécessaire ou c'est
quoi le contexte du marché pour que ça
se produise
dans ce cas ici les deux les deux
présidents se sont rendus compte que en
faisant une fusion comme ça il pouvait
libérer plus de 800 millions sur une
période de cinq à dix ans plus de 800
millions de fonds qui vont aller
directement dans pour les actionnaires
ça veut dire que vous allez avoir une
plus value et en plus en fait la beauté
de ce de cette fusion la sais que vous
allez les actionnaires des deux comptes
ils vont voir une revalorisation très
importante des actions de ces deux
compagnies là et ça change quoi pour les
mines du québec compte parce que nico
détient par exemple le plus grande mine
d'or au canada qui est la canadian
malartic près de val d'or il ya la
rendent également il ya goldex aussi qui
font partie de l'équipage de admis qu
oui amicaux c'est une compagnie déjà
très très canadienne et en créant ce
nouveau jeu ce nouveau géant de deux
compagnies il crée une compagnie qui a
très très peu de risques politiques
parce que lorsque vous regardez à la
production totale de 3.5 millions dans
ce symbole du combat et va venir du
canada 2.5 des deux tiers des 11
viennent du canada ensuite l'australie
et la finlande alors trois pays très
très honnêtement
politiquement stables à comparer à
toutes les autres compagnies aurifères
alors il devrait avoir une prennent le
dessus sur cette nouvelle compagnie noyé
en plus quand vous pensez à ça les
nouvelles compagnies un tiers de ces
employés vont être en fait déjà des
aboriginal des personnes qui étaient ici
alors on pense à une compagnie qui
vraiment et qui sert non seulement les
actionnaires mais aussi les communautés
dans lesquelles ils travaillent
absolument extraordinaire où va le prix
de l'or monsieur la sonde si je me
trompe pas on est à
1760 dans un contexte où on attend aussi
une prochaine hausse des taux d'intérêt
oui en fait la thématique que vous
entendez de tous les gens portefeuille
c'est que l'inflation est transitoire le
fed aux états unis à tous contrôles et
la réalité elle est tellement différente
la réalité c'est si vous allez faire
votre marché votre épicerie fine pas
vous vous rendez compte que l'inflation
et les présente voire des cons que
l'inflation avec les prix de carburant
et l'électricité le gaz naturel tout est
à la hausse alors je ne crois pas que
l'inflation est transitoire et le fed
aux états unis des prix dans une boîte
parce qu'ils ne peut pas vraiment monter
les taux d'intérêt à cause de la d'un
énorme américaine à l'heure actuelle
alors une fois que cette thématique là
va commencer à changer on va se
retrouver à mon avis dans les mêmes
états qu'on a vu dans les amis des
années 70 76 80 quand le prix de l'eau a
commencé à monter d'une façon fulgurante
et à mon avis c'est ce que nous allons
voir dans les prochaines années donc
vous vous pensez que l'inflation va
perdurer au cours des prochains mois
puis même des prochaines années et
qu'elle sera donc l'effet d'une
inflation qui perdure sur le prix de la
évidemment le prix doivent remonter à
penser aux années 70 l'inflation est
passée de 2 à 4 à 6 à 8 à 10 à 12 à 15%
on s'en va prendre des parts dont on
s'en remet au pot l'homme sur la sonde à
moi à mon avis vous allez voir des de
l'inflation à 5 et 8% facilement
possiblement touché des 10% dans un mois
donc glee continue et on regarde que le
prix du duc du gaz naturel il est pas
aussi de 1 dollar 50 à 5 dollars
américains
attendez de voir vos méthodes contre cet
hiver quand vous allez chauffer ça va
faire mal donc il va y avoir beaucoup
impressionné sur certains segments de la
vie mais le taux d'inflation en général
là il est autour de 4 5% est-ce que l'or
je voulais vous demander savent encore
ce kit est ce que l'or intéresse encore
les investisseurs de nos jours
vous avez une segmentation de
générationnel ici quand on parle de la
génération des jeunes ex par exemple et
puis les imaginations le ils sont
beaucoup plus centré sur le crypto pour
l'instant c'est le nouveau truc et puis
les l'or est plutôt resté avec la
génération des années soixante soixante
et qui ont vécu ce alors il ya vraiment
quelque chose de générationnel qui vous
n'êtes pas très crypto vous aussi con
premiers pas du tout je pense que c'est
un pas estimé puis ça va s'écrouler un
moment donné et donc le prix de l'or en
ce moment en 1760 vos projections là
cinq ans par exemple
bah écoute et j'étais aujourd'hui que
quand on regarde l'histoire un moment
donné le prix de l'offre reviers à 1
heure avec le dow jones d'argent c'est à
34 milles et le prix d'entamer ce sens
alors il ya grand gouffre entre les deux
ce sera peut-être pas un mais ça va être
deux à 1 le dedans on sera peut-être pas
34 va être à 10 à 1000 mhz à mon avis
vous allez voir des prix dans beaucoup
plus élevé que nous allons alors que
nous voyons rock c'est toujours un
bonheur de vous accueillir merci pierre
lassonde merci infiniment pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez vous sur la
chaîne ici et redit